welcome to the man of recaps this is
cobra kai season three remember season
two ended on the first day of school
with the all-out karate war it was an
epic brawl between cobra kai and
miyagido which was a real fun time until
people get hurt especially when robbie
kicked miguel so hard he fell over the
balcony and oh no he's falling out
miguel is grievously injured and his
sensei johnny lawrence feels guilty he
renounces cobra kai and karate in
general soon miguel wakes up and he's
kind of okay but he's paralyzed from the
waist down he may never walk again
daniel larusso feels guilty too and also
stops teaching karate he tracks down his
student robbie keane who of course is
johnny lawrence's son he's been on the
run but larosa's like hey kid the best
thing you can do is turn yourself in
which robbie feels is a betrayal johnny
visits his son and tries to make amends
but it's like yo dad you've never been
there for me i don't need or want you in
my life so johnny focuses on helping
miguel who's kind of given up but sensei
lawrence is here to motivate him he's
like hey kid we're going to get you on
your feet again and per usual he uses
ridiculous hilarious training techniques
one of them is going to a classic rock
concert to get in the right headspace
and indeed miguel's foot's a tap-in
alright he's gonna do it meanwhile the
kid's karate rivalry is stronger than
ever but the school's implemented a
zero-tolerance fighting policy so they
have to find creative other ways to kick
each other in the face it ends in a big
fight off-school property at the laser
tag arena where hawk grabs his old best
friend dimitri's arm and no mercy breaks
it ouch yes darth crease has taken over
cobra kai and brought it fully to the
dark side under johnny cobra kai was a
fun place where bullied kids learned to
be tougher but crease is only looking
for natural born cobras anyone without
the killer instinct he kicks right out
in fact he recruits the bullies and has
them fight for a spot in the dojo
kicking out anyone who doesn't make the
cut now these are the guys who used to
bully eli about his lip scar buttholk is
never going back even if it means
becoming one of the bullies he once
hated cobra kai's other starfighter is
tori who's had a real rough life and has
no problem following crease to the dark
side but crease has one more star
recruit in mind robbie keane he's been
having a rough time in juvie and chris
convinces him to drop the miyagido
self-defense and strike for strycard so
when he finally gets out he's got his
real dad and his karate dad but he
rejects them both he joins with crease
his new evil karate grandpa so johnny
continues physical therapy with miguel
and eventually it works miguel's walking
again but now that he's back he finds
his old cobra kai friends have gone to
the dark side so sensei lawrence
realizes he's got to get his old
students back on the right path he's
going to teach karate again so he
gathers up the new cobra kai rejects and
unfortunately he can't use the name
cobra kai anymore he goes with eagle
fang karate which is not as cool in fact
we learned the origin to the name cobra
kai in a john cree's flashback when he
was special forces vietnam and the no
mercy karate you know made sense but his
squad ended up captured and for fun they
made them fight each other to the death
over a pit full of snakes yes it was a
cobra kai meanwhile daniel larusso is
having trouble at his car dealership
with the bad press from the school fight
the japanese manufacturers don't want to
work with him anymore while he's in
japan he visits mr miyagi's old village
which was the setting of karate kid 2
but he finds it different than he
remembers but he runs into some old
friends his love interest from that
movie and the villain and i'm pretty
sure i never saw this one but it looks
like it was wild they're all grown up
now though and agree to be friends in
fact this guy teaches daniel the secret
lost art of the miyagido offense arm
numbing technique and luckily he meets
one more old friend the little girl he
saved from a monsoon who's now a vice
president of the car companies so
there's some business advice for you
save everyone you can from monsoons now
when he gets back and learns how bad
cobra kai's gotten he starts teaching
karate again so his students can defend
themselves so now we have three dojos
miyagido that teaches defense and inner
peace eagle fang karate which is about
being a badass but not an [ __ ] and
cobra kai for those who enjoy being a
villain now remember at the center of
this dojo war is the karate rival love
square mcgill's becoming a better person
as tori's becoming worse so they
officially break up and miguel rekindles
things with his original girlfriend
samantha larusso one night soon their
karate flirting just in time for her new
boyfriend robbie the c and it's the
exact opposite of their scene in season
one where this time robbie's the [ __ ]
so tori and robbie's exes are dating
each other again and these two realize
they have a lot in common they don't
hook up yet but it's inevitable there's
another funny romance between dimitri
and season one's hot mean girl yasmin
she skipped season two she was in paris
for the summer and by the way aisha is
not back this season her parents moved
away but the atomic wedgie aisha gave
her has made her a bit of a better
person and dimitri's newfound karate
confidence eventually wears her down
these two get together the adults find
love too remember johnny has a crush on
miguel's mom and they went on one date
last season and the way to a woman's
heart is to help her paralyzed son
miraculously walk again so these two
finally get it on but there's a
complication when johnny finally figures
out facebook and has a friend request
from ali mills his high school
girlfriend the one that got away she's
in town for the holidays so they meet up
and have a great time it's too bad she's
married now but turns out she's recently
divorced oh it's on but remember she
wasn't just johnny's high school
girlfriend she dated larusso too these
old rivals almost break into a karate
fight right here but luckily daniel's
wife is here to bring us all back down
to reality have the man boys filled you
in on the whole mortal enemy karate dojo
battling for the soul the valley thing
so they all have a great night together
and ali helps these two realize if they
weren't so committed to being enemies
they could be good friends and as for
the romance johnny doesn't pursue it he
just started dating miguel's mom so
these two are just friends now sam and
miguel work together to squash the beef
between their dojos so they can unite
against cobra kai it's not gonna work
the beef is too strong but cobra kai
crashes the party so they have to work
together and it's time for another
season finale epic karate fight yeah
now miguel's been training really hard
but it's a long road to recovery in fact
he should absolutely not be part of this
fight and now hawk realizes he's
fighting with his bullies against his
best friends what am i doing yes it's
time for hawk to switch sides oh yeah
best nerd friends reunited so working
together they beat cobra kai for now but
when johnny learns what happens he busts
into secrece and finds him training his
son robbie no you were the chosen one
you were supposed to bring balance to
the force not leave it in darkness so
johnny finally has a fight with crease
but robbie steps in and it's a
father-son fight that daniel russo comes
to ready for some offense oh yeah karate
then at the end boom uses the new arm
numbing trick he learned and crease is
defeated but he's not surrendering yet
you may have won this battle but let's
settle this the old-fashioned way at the
all valley under 18 karate tournament
and so the original kobra kai and
miyagido beefs are squashed for good
they're combining dojos to take down new
evil cobra kai and even the adults
johnny lawrence and danny larusso agree
to put their lifelong rivalry on pause
they're gonna be co-senseis and with
their wildly different styles it's gonna
be hilarious and that's where cobra kai
season three comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member